rien ne semble arrêter Beauval et son
développement après la construction du
dôme équatorial ou des télécabines le
parc est actuellement en plein travaux
pour réaliser la plus grande volière
d'Europe un chantier titanesque de 14
millions d'euros au printemps prochain
public devrait pouvoir découvrir ce
nouvel espace et ses habitants des
oiseaux d'Amérique du Sud visitent en
avant-première avec les la Turquie
bientôt les cris des oiseaux
remplaceront le ronronnement des
perceuses la grande volière sud
américaine de Beauval prend forme visite
guidée avec Rodolphe Delort le directeur
du parc on peut en des très grands
arbres on met aussi des très grands
arbres morts pour qu'ils sachent puisse
monter à 20 mètres de haut des arbres
plantés et des ponts de Saint-Jean
construction Beauval voit les choses en
grand
chute d'eau tout autour qui pourra
autour de ses pierres en bas il y aura
un bassin un chantier d'envergure avec
un filet en inox suspendu à 35 mètres de
hauteur surface totale près de deux
hectares pour la plus grande volière
d'Europe futur lieu d'accueil de plus de
500 oiseaux et une trentaine de
mammifères l'idée c'était que ces
oiseaux nos oiseaux sud-américains
puissent vouer sur des grandes distances
c'est toujours pour le bien-être de nos
animaux pour que nos visiteurs passent
un moment de rêve d'émerveillement de
sensibilisation à conservation de notre
biodiversité menacée investissement
total 14 millions d'euros sur le
chantier des entreprises locales avec un
maximum de matériaux français et comme
toujours raboval depuis 15 ans le projet
est imaginé à deux Rodolphe Delort
accompagné par l'architecte Daniel
boitte c'est important de voir la
conception générale à partir d'une
grande passerelle qui est au-dessus du
vide et pourquoi l'eau dessus du vide
tout simplement pour être au milieu des
oiseaux comme ça on a l'impression nous
aussi nous les Terriens de voler est-ce
qu'il y a une grande particularité à
Beauval c'est que il y a un engouement
général pour créer quelque chose qui
sort de l'ordinaire et comme ici les
projets de construction ne s'arrêtent
jamais l'entrée sud fermée pour
restructuration complète doit rouvrir au
début du mois prochain pour la période
estivale quant à la grande volière
inauguration prévue le samedi 8 avril